بالعوده مشاهدينا الى قصه الاختفاء مفتشوا
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كانوا قد
اكتشفوا خلال عمليه تفتيش اختفاء عشره
براميل تحتوي على ما يقارب
2.5 طن من اليورانيوم الطبيعيه هذه المواد
كانت ليبيا قد ابلغت عنها باعتبارها مخزنه
قبل اختفائها احد المواقع المعلنه لاختفاء
اليورانيوم منها كانت قرب مطار سبها اي
على بعد حوالي 660 كيلومترا جنوب شرق
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس حيث قامت ليبيا
تحت حكم معمر القذافي بتخزين الاف
البراميل مما يسمى يورانيوم الكعكه
الصفراء في حين ازال المفتشون اخر
اليورانيوم المخصب بليبيا عام 2009 ظلت
الكعكه الصفراء موجوده في مكانها وكان
اختفاء هذه الكميه الكبيره من اليورانيوم
الطبيعي اثارت مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامه
وانتشار الاسلحه لماذا لان كل طن من
اليورانيوم في حال فرضيه وقوعها بيد جهه
لديها الوسائل والموارد والتكنولوجيا
كاجهزه الطرد المركزيه يمكنها تحويله الى
خمسه فاصله سته كيلو جرامات من المواد
المستخدمه في صنع الاسلحه لكن تلك المخاوف
تبددت لاحقا طبعا بعد عثور الجيش على
الكميه وتجدر الاشاره هنا ايضا الى انه لا
يمكن استخدام اليورانيوم الطبيعيه على
الفور لانتاج الطاقه او وقود القنابل لان
عمليه التخصيم تتطلب اعاده تحويل المعدن
الى غاز ثم يتم تدويره لاحقا في اجهزه
الطرد المركزي للوصول الى المستويات
المطلوبه
[موسيقى]